greetings from podcast village Wednesday
March 9th or whatever the [ __ ] March
11th listen I know it's Wednesday you
don't feel good oh my god the
coronavirus I don't know what I'm gonna
do but let's start off with a little
bong hit and you'll be [ __ ] tip-top
Magoo you understand me
the church is brought to you by Stan's
calm listen
time is money baby stop wasting time
going to the post office and you can use
stamps calm no more waiting in line like
in the post office like a mall mall
which stamps.com you can do everything
that the mailman does anyway or the
postman whatever the [ __ ] you want to
call them listen my wife's been using
stat stamps.com for years we've been
sending up t-shirts and sweatshirts and
coffee mugs of stamps calm
stamps.com brings the US Postal Service
to you whether you're a small business
or warehouse sending out thousands of
packages stamps.com can handle all do me
a favor stop going to the post office
you stamps.com right now they got a
special offer for the first church
family you ready for this especially now
with this [ __ ] coronavirus you don't
want to be going to post office down
online people breathing down your neck
and [ __ ] there's always somebody from
some other [ __ ] third world nation
working this [ __ ] up and right now the
church before we drop let's post into
digital scale nobodies were no long-term
commitments or contracts all right it's
easy you go to status com click the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and press in church that stamps.com
press in church never go to the post
office again it's [ __ ] creepy best
anyway
my guest today is my main man and the
best interviewer I know
mr. Ryan Sickler and thank you
the flying Jew is also in house what's
up dawg
thank you for having me back man that's
that's high praise right there the best
interviewer you know yes you know I
don't open up to little buddy a point
you open up to you
you've wept on my show of all times
you've been moved quite a bit I'm very
impressed by it as always so thank you
for having me back
it's really fun when you people think I
love when people call you up and go hey
I just want to be in your pocket you
know what I don't even [ __ ] know you
if you look at the podcast you have high
numbers with its people you have a
feeling with that's right you share
mutual love with me can I see the love
gets picked up on the airwaves and
people call their friends and say I
listen to this podcast it's kind of
special it's not special they've already
that they are you eat they've already
heard the stories it's the electricity
between two people speaking which is
what I like the most about podcasts
that's why I don't like [ __ ] 18
people in a room when I do a podcast I
don't like I like the intimacy I'm
one-on-one conversation you know once
you have six mics going eight mics going
you have nine different energies and
that it's that one-on-one love and
people feel that when I'm with your
podcasts a girl's podcast Triple E Eddie
Bravo numbers are always good because
the love is there Rogan and the millions
yeah red bandana millions because the
love is there and people don't seem to
get that Isis podcast is the last eight
nine years you know yesterday I got hit
up by some [ __ ] I want to start a
podcast where we get hot and spicy
chicken nuggets like nobody's done that
spicy chicken [ __ ] line like that you
know saying Mike I don't only non spicy
chicken table and I really
hot wings it's a it's on truTV now I got
a feather in my cap yes it anomalies
eyes and spicy chicken what are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] the host is to kiss a
debt and the two other guy what are you
gonna do for me get the show started and
get back to me what if you do three
episodes and somebody dies and that
[ __ ] Chinese chicken his knowledge I
gotta be a part of that in the coconut
yeah I'm I'm in the [ __ ] in there in
the [ __ ] you know people just don't
get it that there's a limit that I
disappear once it comes to podcast when
you call me with like a [ __ ] game
show type podcast you're in no danger
oh yes you did that whatever I'll put
you you know if you're gonna be that
stupid I got a call from a dear friend
of mine that wanted me to do a podcast
on the Sunday in a [ __ ] like a sauna
with nothing no clothes on and I might
hang are you press or Sunday is the
Lord's Day number two on Sundays I don't
really know what I want to do day I'm
just flying back from the show the night
before 50% of their time and I really
don't know what I want to do Sunday
mornings are my favorite in the world
because my wife and baby leave to church
at 9:00 not to my type of church some
other religion whatever that [ __ ]
Christianity was there's no chickens of
all there's no chickens involved there's
no rape and there's no practice um
saying I might daughter brought home one
of those Catholic chocolates the a day
it tastes like be tough priests penis um
she's like look daddy I go in flavors it
and in my head I said priest beat it and
I could tell that the chocolate later on
[Laughter]
my chocolate so oh my god so that's what
well we're gonna get your full life
story we're good doing it I mean III I
don't you cut this is probably gonna
come out the same week or or your
episode all which we've already recorded
will come out no this is a your weekend
two weeks after after I'm saying your
episode for mine we already recorded
another episode with you on the honeydew
yes and that's probably gonna come out
in the same about a week or two right
and I think we're only I mean what are
we where I called him to Denver days we
just got into Denver so you're early
twenties I think and then we're gonna do
your we are gonna do your whole life
story until we get to current we're
gonna crawl breed a I put away an hour
to write something and I've been pretty
successful with it it's been working
well and you your memories is them your
memory doesn't really open up until you
start opening it up and reading it back
I've been catching the coffee shop where
I go on you have to know them well our
day lately just one or one hour and 15
minutes I park and got a green tea and I
just write out and I was started on
drugs and it's hilarious like this
nights I city with Lee if I fortunately
believe oath knows I love him Leo call
me next day I got so [ __ ] up on them
leave go I don't know how he did it
until this day people cannot realize
even I feel it like when people give me
a pill that says kill the [ __ ] I did two
pills about a year and a half ago I want
to do a podcast in the people at junkies
and they had a bag of pills and they
gave me like a pill and a half and I am
my god city and why I got [ __ ] up but
that's the day you all Romero came right
and I had to do a podcast with yo well
then we had to go eat chicken Cuban food
and I could was surprised on how well I
kept it together it was a percocet and
the right thing like something else I
was high for eight hours straight yes
but I from my experiences as a young man
I kept it together and I started writing
this thing for March 25th at the time is
still about addictions you know my
addiction
throughout all this story I have
mentioned to you guys what at 14 if you
were to come up to me and said Joey you
are you ever gonna be interested in
doing coke or whatever I'd probably beat
the [ __ ] out here but at 14 at dirt I
probably started smoking pot at 12 and a
half let's just be safe
let's just be safety in light of each
other
twelve and a half thirteen very subtly
once a month
it went from once a month and is this
floating through the bar or is this
through the school just like kid or kids
in the neighborhood of the neighborhood
downtown all right we had that thing
called the woods and we would roll three
joints you sucked on it and he left a
thing going all the airway yeah we would
make them with toilet paper rolls are
the same thing with toilet paper like
gravity has a little bit of form yeah so
we were doing all that in those days it
was very hush-hush it was me and three
other kids and same age kids yeah we had
the Visine the Binaca get yeah yeah and
then we'd walk through this diner on
tumbly Avenue that did not existed it
was a real redneck trucker diner and
they have like the music on the wall you
know like when you spin it yeah play
songs and we'd go in there listen to
Margaritaville and just [ __ ] another
way to succumb and she'd be like 40 and
ugly she smoked like a thousand
cigarettes and she was three and [ __ ]
we laugh at her
we just start laughing the house she'd
give us the menus the steaks I'll come
back when you grow up
oh [ __ ] like that it started like a fun
thing and then we started by the 8th
grade we're doing it in between classes
sometimes like three of us to get
together and smoke a joint go back to
class a lit up
and start making noises in class and
giggling the whole thing and then it was
just a slow process I knew that I just
liked marijuana
mm-hmm I knew the dangers of cocaine and
the dangers of heroin but then a friend
of mine came to me anyone Danny was
let's do it acid I was the Rolling
Stones in eighth grade my eighth grade
graduation that was his present for me
he goes I'm taking you to see the stones
we got taking a hit of windowpane acid
I'm like huh here we go they go how bad
could it be it was bad but I went to the
car tonight
you know I'm late then I kind of like
that I like where it took me I like to
go home a listen to music and I would
pop acid again once a month for a while
but it became twice a month and then it
became a thing that we do three nights a
week
damn with tripping for how long how many
years this one up this for a year
November we were doing hits acid three
and week three a week and is it just one
hit a night or doubling up on those no
no one all right one would take you if
you did it six you'd be cooking till
3:00 and I mean cooking like you could
go home by yourself somebody told me a
story one time acid shrooms opium things
like that didn't come through our way
until the Grateful Dead came to town we
would all go to the parking lot we party
at the Capitol Center back in the day
where they did heavy metal parking lot
that's the capital Center were there for
the Grateful Dead
and I didn't smoke or anything but
everybody I hung out with it and I never
minded that they did I kind of enjoyed
like seeing what happened I was like
okay well I'm not gonna do cocaine well
I'm not gonna do [ __ ] rails I'm not but
one of our friends somebody told me this
I I I hope this is [ __ ] true but I
guess he had bought a sheet of acid put
it in his pocket to take back with us
later that night and it rained
and the rain washed the [ __ ] acid
into his skin and his kin and he was
they said he was they had taken to the
hospital
come on
that's it could see fit I guess it could
right it's just a doll that I was clean
and sober I was clean and sober oh okay
I was clean and sober they threatened me
with [ __ ] going back to prison and
finishing my sentence and one day I get
a call like that's the positive for
cocaine and I go I don't I don't snort
the cocaine I just sell it and I told
that to a friend of mine he goes are you
[ __ ] it was every time he touched
those rocks that stuff goes through your
skin she got that spot one time I tested
positive I wasn't even doing it it was
from touching it so yes I need a story
especially back then the acid was
thicker I never [ __ ] it look you gave
me shrooms you just gave me the Comedy
Store at the last okay was it they were
good I had them that I had some that
night and then I still have what you
gave me to take home with me I got a bag
at the house but I want to I'll tell you
this so when I first moved out here
because I've only done shrooms like five
times and at one point I enjoyed it but
also I'm gonna sleep I'm the guy that's
like all right it's been five hours get
the [ __ ] out of here you know I'm like
that with company you know I mean get
the alright it's you know hey dad we had
a good time get the [ __ ] out it you
don't need I don't need to still be here
in my music or Wawa blah blah after five
[ __ ] hours you know you know I get it
but back when I first lived here this
was this was in the 1900s man this was
97 bro late 1900s 1997 I first moved
here to go to college
and that was the whole Northridge quake
I was coming here to go to Northridge
when the quake hit and destroyed the
school so I ended up going anyway but I
was I found an apartment for a month
then moved in and in February and Pink
Floyd is coming out to the Rose Bowl and
I
love Pink Floyd and I want to go see
Pink Floyd and I want to see him at the
[ __ ] Rose Bowl so my buddy and I get
tickets and he tells me a married couple
that he knows I was gonna meet us there
and sit with us as well as like great so
the four of us are hanging out we're all
smoking weed and three of them decide to
do shrooms and I'm like I'm good I'm
just gonna smoke weed and drink get into
the show this show is [ __ ] bananas I
don't know if you ever seen pink I got
to see him here in in DC at RFK when
that was still there same summer and the
pigs are [ __ ] bounce and you know
they're all tripping over there on their
oaths are on their shrooms and [ __ ]
and I look to my left you've been in a
rose bowl you're packed in there you
know and I look back to my right and my
friend Kevin he's gone he's gone
and I and people start yelling and [ __ ]
I look back this [ __ ] passed out
okay and it's those bleacher seats so
when he went back his feet got hooked
under the back of the front one and he
bent in half and people instead of
catching them they got scared and they
jumped out of the way his head hits the
bleachers behind him he goes into a
full-on seizure okay he's going crazies
eyes and they're like is he Apple is he
epileptic I'm like I don't [ __ ] know
I have no idea the chit were you
tripping no I only smoked weed and drank
but the three of them they're all to my
right it's him and then the married
couple she sees it and I think guilt got
to her everything because she's the one
that gave him the shrooms she starts
throwing up in her like $50 concert
shirt she hurt she's they're all have a
feather all having a bad trip was he's
having a full [ __ ] seizure I've never
seen this all mushrooms okay and I don't
know if it's the truth of the fact that
he hit his head so goddamn hard on this
thing but I don't know what to do and I
look up at her and she's you know she's
seated like oh my god it's coming for me
next you know that mines every uh and I
just start smacking them as hard as I
can in the [ __ ] face I'm smacking the
[ __ ] out of them Pink Floyd the pigs are
[ __ ] going oh I just lost my
headphone sorry and they're banging and
banging and banging and he's having a
seizure and then finally he snaps out of
and everybody's like holy Sh I'm like
dude or you are he's like did I just
pass out I'm like yeah yeah I go how
long do you think you were out he's like
I don't know
for like three three minutes he's like
yeah I was like you're out for about 15
seconds I was like dude but you had a
[ __ ] seizure you bleeding as if I'm
not bleeding I'm like are you alright
he's like yeah look over her they're out
they're gone we never saw them again we
go back to [ __ ] Pink Floyd and he's
fine the rest of the night meet these
weak people I went to a million cars
wave everything but heroin balls and
nobody ever [ __ ] played if that
happened in my name but you have to move
to the next day I have to pick up a move
at the [ __ ] leader of constant I gave
a couple mushrooms is it [ __ ] take
straight up ass and I took acid to Ted
Nugent ac/dc
I took cats I didn't take acid to Black
Sabbath I was too young but I took acid
to all those you ever um you ever smoked
weed dipped in PCP sure what I sure more
know well this is what I was getting
okay that I are you so I'm sixteen the a
I'm laughing at age 16 yeah I'm going
that transition and I'm doing mic
without acid that's what it was called
it wasn't really that was his little
like one hit tab
I mean tiny he would lose it you had you
had a rapid in aluminum foil to see them
and yeah take lightly a little before
and they fit on the floor you were done
sometimes it was purple sometimes it was
pink sometimes it was brown but it was a
size in the Miller skill that was the
most popular acid it was 50/50 was
basically rat poison you did it it was
strychnine you'd be grinding your teeth
moving around Oh tremendous but you went
for [ __ ] eight to 12 hours that's a
law that's a hard huh yeah you know now
you like oh thank god that's gone I'm
anxiety here and said I give you another
bunkie do another bond and wake it up
and then you said the Sun set and you're
like oh thank God I can go home now you
home and you drink milk and you go up to
your room you lay down awesome the
posters start moving again it was that
type of [ __ ] my kid just did not go away
and then see well this is not a sales
point everyone's ever told me though
just great than the one I did to the to
the stones honestly that was the first
time I had done that drug and I wrote
about this it was like a three day
recovery for three [ __ ] happen
whistles and electronic shot someone
through my spine like I was just a young
kid though I think I gotta stop this
[ __ ] like I really do like I had only
done it once but then it was just too
much fun it was the drugs of the era it
was the drug of this like how many I
want to tell you you know the karlon bit
where he talks about acid right it's
like self-regulating at some point it'll
say stop you know just like the word da
No so but how many hits would you say
you've had well then let's just say that
let's just do it by freshman year Jesus
precious year was when we really started
cooking with gas with the ass that's
three a week we would just we would
three a week and then something new came
along people were saying you got us not
this [ __ ] now I had always made a
promise to myself that I would never
smoke nothing but they were like it's
just THC stems its stems and people boil
them and they shut the thing off and the
white powder that sticks on this side
they scraped that off and that's what
you snorting it's harmless laughs ah and
it was I had like this I had 18 friends
but there was always for that were like
kind of smart and they were the ones I
got want to do it I'm like you sure
so after weeks of trying I said let me
do a lot of that THC crystal the Keith
like that Keith that's on the crystals
on the weed it was white and you're
snore I've never heard this one this is
brand new to me
small exploited and we would do it first
i did it and i gave it a break i went
back the house but what kind of high is
it like what do you feel like [ __ ]
Gumby like you're about like everything
is just [ __ ] flashing again is it a
different high than an acid trip it is
eventually I kept doing it and doing it
so I got to the point where my mother
would go to the track on Sunday so I
knew she was gonna be how long day I
mean this kid Carlos Perez ten dollar
package of it and we need to get a
six-pack of Lowenbrau I remember alone
brought a lion that like ally here
tonight is goddess must save something
more but how tonight let it be lower bro
sponsor the church loan Brownlow and
brass so [ __ ] we would get long for
house and gets locked up and then go on
journeys we just walked and talked [ __ ]
I want to be a doctor Harmonia and we
just be like cars are almost hit us the
way that type is [ __ ] we would be [ __ ]
up and I found that it was actually
angel dust and they turn them into a
powder you buckets so we used to play
either or we should play again either we
do acid or we do that's what it was
called
until one day somebody said stupid wake
up ah you spawned animal tranquilizers
how long had you been doing it would you
say before you actually found out what
I like Mamba sitting there going hey
surprise me you get [ __ ] up you know
what can you explain listen they said
lose the drug dealers that died it was
loose been paid out I mean one time with
a pregnant chick in 1983 they would they
would sell it in Harlem and you could
smoke and it was called the Trey
it was three dollars it was a tray and
it was basically enough powder to
sprinkle a joint with and you just
smoked it and that was that was maybe
December January February of 84 no no
baby three maybe December of 82 it was
cold out and being on the bus at nine
o'clock
Kennedy Boulevard drop me off on the
corner and crossing the street to the
bow like I walked in and I was still a
little Gumby dust
there's none it was just called Gumby
dust and yeah so I wanted to tear that
[ __ ] me and my buddies were tearing that
stuff up that's why today like I said
before I don't know what day I'm gonna
go onstage [ __ ] in my hand and take it
out and float at the audience cuz one of
these days one of these cylinders are
gonna snap yeah and the real Joey D is
gonna come out the Mensch is definitely
in my future especially if we did these
this [ __ ] at the age of 13 the answer
early that's hard stuff early too early
I party so hard my freshmen going to
sophomore year so I got put in the
hospital at some time because I had a
lung infection and they threw me out on
September 28 1979 and I got out of
hospital 11 o'clock at 8:00
like that night I was smoking dope and
doing a sleek Jesus Christ it's like
Muhammad Ali fought somebody I still
have more corn I'm on my brother's
ex-wife's house is on that corner I know
what house we sound the steps like and I
and I kept doing that powder and I kept
snorting that [ __ ] and then one day I
walked into the basement
and my mom had these friends that she
would hold [ __ ] for downstairs but it
was always weed bales of weed like
coffee beans and bales and I would take
a little off the top and I would spray
it with water to maintain the way yeah
like the holes in heavy so when they put
on the scale I was a [ __ ] Gina oh
it's great and I [ __ ] but one time I
went down and then it wasn't
I wouldn't do that [ __ ] oh my god I felt
Chinese people you know it was it was
real cocaine this [ __ ]
everyone wants a large scrape alone take
it and give it to him this one on for
about a month or two then the guy became
a cop so now helm you know I knew
usually do something with his life he
became a cop well now I own them but
that's not the point of the story I held
on to that one one dad took it and I
would surprise him like in 1979 and
somebody would surprise you with cocaine
you pretty much suck this day
in 1979 walking into a room with cocaine
those two chicks are gonna suck your
dick
they knew forget Harvey won't sting you
you'd make Harvey Weinstein look like a
[ __ ] gay night that's how strong the
power of cocaine was guys like me get
laid
women were doing disgusting things it
was a different level of disgust because
it meant you had power it was like this
social you came out of the bathroom and
you went the whole bar would look even
come over and rub your shoulders how is
it oh it's semi intense yeah that goes
more like 54 this is cocaine freedom
makes me you know so that shit's old it
made white people go crazy but at the
same time I hadn't done it I held on to
have a little package but the night
before some cats call me Ivan though
they were playing okay tomorrow so I
said [ __ ] when they bring the packets
and see if one but these guys are too
straight there was like eight of us but
one of the other dudes was a genius and
him and I used to do [ __ ] that angel
busts [ __ ] that's cool from time to time
the one that gave my line he thought it
was high school wrestler like me ha and
he was on the bottom and he made a movie
bit the guy we got disqualified that's
what we all called to avoid the pain of
what it really right yeah my brother he
and a buddy I actually told this whole
story on my album but he no and uh a
cousin brought some [ __ ] home one time
and they called it Sherm it was a and
and they would call Paul Chuck Paul
that's what they called PCP Paul Chuck
Paul and they would uh it was popular
for a little while to dip this [ __ ] in
PCP these joints and I thought it was a
myth at first I was like I thought now
because you hear [ __ ] on like Oprah
people doing it dipping their cigarettes
and
they're babies and [ __ ] like insane
stuff that these suffocating kids and
freezers like and they decide to smoke
it in front of me and you know I tell
that story but the thing was I thought
it was a one and done thing for them you
know what I mean like I knew they had
done it but it's like the summer 94 I'm
fresh off the Pink Floyd concert I go
back to Maryland for the summer before
between college and I'm seeing this girl
at the time and we're going to
Lollapalooza now originally Nirvana was
gonna headline I'm almost positive it's
94 and then Cobain died so he brought
the Smashing Pumpkins in to fill that
space and it was a great was like Tribe
Called Quest I think the Beastie Boys
were there [ __ ] p-funk was there the
Smashing Pumpkins like it was it was a
good one and they're smoking a joint and
I don't think anything up I just think
it's a joint and the girl I'm seeing at
the time goes over to take a hit you
know she smokes weed and she comes back
she's like that tasted really weird and
I was like you [ __ ] and I went
over to my brother I'm like is that
[ __ ] weed or is that that [ __ ] you
were smoking they know it's just before
I go what are you [ __ ] you got you
can't just let some you gotta tell
somebody that well we thought she knew
I'm like why would anyone assume that
you're smoking PCP laced weed over here
why would anyone why would that be your
immediate it probably should be the way
you treat life but why would anyone
assume that anyway and this poor girl I
mean she tripped out of her [ __ ] mind
for an hour I mean she missed off she
missed the whole [ __ ] show she she
finally collapsed and slept for hours
but when she woke up and she is she was
in shape fit you know slender this
[ __ ] girl was she was starving like a
[ __ ] hostage and I told them you know
what your penalties gonna be you're
gonna [ __ ] feed her whatever she
wants at these goddamn festival prices
and this chick I mean she ate for a
family I've never seen anything like it
and she's like I can't believe I'm still
hungry she's just going I was like eat
it up girl eat it all make these
[ __ ] buy they spent $300 or so
in food just for her to starve I mean
I've never seen and then I went to
dinner with her when I went back to Mara
just not not too long ago and we're
sitting at dinner and I don't say
anything she goes she goes remember that
time your brother had me smoke BZ yeah
water if you're gonna bring that [ __ ]
she's like I've never eaten so much of
my life she's a mom and she's like yeah
so sorry about that idea he was like all
that [ __ ] was just so I don't know what
to call it not ill-advised I don't know
it was kind of ill-advised yeah because
I would just always seem dirty to me you
know what I mean like like literally
dirty like it's just a physical dirty
drug like cocaine seemed I don't know
why I know it's cut and everything but
Blake you're tall my pure weeds pretty
much untouched shrooms are untouched
it's once people put their real [ __ ]
hands on it really [ __ ] they are
grounded yeah how they taste yeah I'll
try the capsule you have what you have
shroom capsules oh yeah that's right now
uncle Gio uncle Joey's high-tech shroom
capsules for the mind soul and spirit
are you working on sound net yeah all
you need to do yes it's gonna go it's
going legal in some states I believe in
micro dog it's Colorado right now even
putting in capsules I'm weighing them
out and I believe that you should get a
little spirit of life everyday
especially if you go into a depression
it's proven no one knows anything that's
right it's good for you for triangles
pain opiates all that [ __ ] is destroying
aren't they yes those the gain-a-tron
nobody gets in trouble for efj except
that black guy knew yo got beat the [ __ ]
out it which is again take those late
offices and [ __ ] get rid of them
listen if you're a cop and you know I
have the utmost respect for you police
officers across the country you have the
toughest job in the world but do me a
favor you're not [ __ ] the rookies and
this is not 1960 if somebody's smoking
pot who gives a [ __ ] there are more
important things to worry about
world right now that some guy on the
corner smoking [ __ ] pot if you watch
that video it's a very embarrassed it is
I who raised you guys serious you pulled
your gun out and put it in his stomach
and now New York or answer back he was a
rapist who got out of jail with some
fake [ __ ] [ __ ] that doesn't cover
what happened you didn't know that going
into that situation yeah that's called
hindsight honey this 92 states with
illegal now if you're a cop as a police
officer save yourself the aggravation as
a human and the embarrassment it's let
live listen somebody's kicking an old
lady I pull the [ __ ] over
somebody's kicking a homeless guy I'm
pulling the [ __ ] over it's so funny to
say I'm homeless guy I stop over here
I'm calling every time right what is
that Cahuenga
riverside there's a left when I have to
go to cry oh oh I gotta go weed I got it
make a right on that corner there's a
[ __ ] hole mollenkamp
yeah every time I stop that oh well I
throw the guy a dollar you know I will
be yourself some coffee a little dignity
two dollars I gave the guy had a handful
of changed I gotta hide from the [ __ ]
power wash between [ __ ] damn in the
Ballet's every time I give them my car
my quarters a gun no for [ __ ]
quarters and now remember if you steal
dollar from every car you make an extra
fifty a night that's how I learned not
to keep weed in my car every time I left
in the car these [ __ ] were
calling you take your change and you
know the bagging you put in the glove
compartment you close the glove
compartment and then when you leave you
take the baggie out that's the only way
you trick these [ __ ] idiots because
that's I say you know you live in
Hollywood you live in North Hollywood
Studio City
you're [ __ ] there's always a [ __ ]
meter you know so yeah then you don't
have any change and those meters you
don't get much of your mileage ladies
and gentlemen you put a corner on a
minimun Torah you gonna make three
minutes yeah you put you need to meet
somebody for an hour you [ __ ] and give
you your election results for the
Russian
five the [ __ ] parking spot I gotta
put an ATF machine in
there's gonna be three [ __ ] dollars
and dimes and nickels I'm the same way
about you see an old person yeah this is
just happened the other day we were
walking I was with my daughter's mother
and my daughter were walking in the
Target and call her City right and I see
this this this little caddy parked in
the handicap spot right up front there's
unexcused me when you say mother and
mothers daughters because you don't
marry to the woman that's right yeah we
were naming him thank you very much from
that same baby's mama like some
third-world nation [ __ ] cannibal
people think it's [ __ ] classy to say
baby's mom even she says bate she says
it sometimes she goes why don't you say
that I said because I have I own a grown
men that's what I said and I said I say
babies mama give him more respect so
exactly what I said I said you're more
than well that's right you're I can't
stand the dirty [ __ ] yeah how are you
that's what is right now you know she's
not my fiancee she's not my wife she's
my daughter's mother and yeah I don't
know stab no no no but we're we're doing
much better and we get along very well
and I said well I always say to I your
more I said look you know we had a real
coming to this year where I was like you
know everybody's got their hand in my
pocket for a percentage of this or that
no matter what I do whatever we all do
and I said the person who actually helps
me the most is you when we have split
custody but when I'm on the road you
either watch our daughter or you make
sure she has child care you make sure
she's fed safe whatever I can walk
onstage coming for the confident and
free of any worries and I said you know
what you're the [ __ ] [ __ ] so I
started doing nice things for her I was
like why is everybody else but you know
so we have this understanding and an
agreement now but we were walking into
Target and there's this old lady sitting
in the passenger seat of this caddy up
front the parking space and there's an
older man standing over and he's like I
[ __ ] hate you mom and I was like whoa
and he looks like he's probably in his
60s and she looks like she's in her
and he was heated and she was just
sitting there like this and I told her
us a hole on a second
that's what's wait right here this guy
this guy looks like he might actually
hit this lady and he's just screaming at
her and screaming at her and then I look
at Don and I'm like you know I don't
know he might be right yeah I don't know
the story over there but I'm gonna make
sure this old lady's not in harm's way
and then I he shut the door and that was
the end of it but I'm the same way over
for that [ __ ] everything else like leave
people to walk alone understand
sometimes when I say pull over you know
somebody's kicking somebody you pull
over but there's some situations you
mind your business yes because I got my
ticket come out and shoot you for being
nosey Rosie I'm old school New York I
don't make eye contact when I keep
walking I didn't know nothing I hear
nothing
excuse me said you witnessed that I
don't know nothing you know I blow I
first moved into this apartment in
Baltimore with my brother and I come
home from ups at night shout out the UPS
pomeroy primary one joy Avenue I worked
the graveyard shift I get home like 3:30
in the morning and I'm not in the place
15 there's cops everywhere and I'm like
oh man and I knew that we had just had a
party because we were just moved in
everybody smoking and drinking and I'm
like [ __ ] these [ __ ] what we're
gonna get evicted are it's got to be
them whatever and they're all the cops
are all on that and the way it was this
apartment complex you'd enter these
glass doors and then you could go
upstairs or downstairs and it's you know
that it's like New Yorkers in a way
where his apartment here here here here
here here is like six of them right
there you know in the little corridor
and the cops are like you can go ahead
and where do you live I'm like right
here in 12 they're like go ahead so I go
in our place I shut the [ __ ] door I'm
trying to wake my brother up he's asleep
drunk I look out the blinds cops have
their guns drawn what the [ __ ] is going
on here and now I'm looking out the
peephole it's my first or second night
in this place okay here come the cops
with the battering ram down the [ __ ]
stairs oh my god holy [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] going on but it could and I'm
like they wouldn't let me come in if it
was for my place you know and then right
across I mean the door across my
peephole right there
it's not that much farther than that
wall right there where I am and I'm
standing straight up and these cops got
the battering ram there yo open the
[ __ ] door will open the [ __ ] door
and the guy nothing and they just boom
they bang it open they start yet they're
all running in with their guns and
they're like we know the guns in here
and I'm like wow I died of I guess I
thought bullets were just gonna come fly
throughout and over over everybody can
I'm crawling back down the hallway I'm
like get on the floor [ __ ] get
on the floor they brought this black
dude out I'll tell you what his girl was
a [ __ ] G cuz she didn't give him up
she didn't give him up she didn't give
the gun I'm [ __ ] of anything they
drug his ass out and they put him they
had his hands behind his back and they
put him on the stairs you know how steps
go like this they put his head up on
this part of the step and his shoulder
down this part of step and they put
their knees on this [ __ ] neck
in the gap where it is let me tell you
some that [ __ ] bent 90 degree they were
[ __ ] going on him and he was
screaming he wouldn't give it up they
were [ __ ] him up on those steps they
take him out then they go in and they
start yelling at her and she doesn't
give anything up she's like nah tin here
I don't know what you're talking about
snot and she they were screaming she was
not intimidated at [ __ ] all day
bounced out of there I'm like holy [ __ ]
this is like night one night two and
then they come knocking on everybody's
door and they're like you know did you
see anything did you hear anything I was
like I didn't I didn't see her hear
anything I just gone in the back I was
in the shower
my brother's sleeping we didn't hear
anything door shut and nobody ever [ __ ]
with us after that this is a
neighborhood that we found out the hard
way - we order pizza and they're like
yeah we don't deliver to you at night I
was like what there were so many people
that would just order a pizza and then
robbed a delivery driver of his money
and the food that after dark you had to
go pick it up Papa John's would not
deliver to our [ __ ] neighborhood
after dark that's where we live for a
year delivery boy one time you bought
the delivery boy we were kids 88th
Street parked at two houses across from
it so we would run to Kirk DiLaurentis
house
and call it the Chinese delivery guy to
meet us at that house but we'd be 10 of
us on 88th Street Park and as soon as he
pulled up listen one night one of the
kids got in and stole the car and
actually started making the little
reader and [ __ ] left the car we were
crazy that good one that we held the
garlic at knifepoint and took his money
for coking like 11:30 that was the cops
game we had a run the whole [ __ ] deal
but the night that the kid and I can't
remember his name and I have a friend of
mine that I grew up with a driver truck
Tim eh
he listens to podcasts he'll remember
and two days I'll call over there we go
oh you're talking about that guy that
with that story was huge in my hometown
this kid was that crazy got in the dudes
car
it made the delivery made three delivery
pulled over just walked home and he took
it all along with him whatever was in
there was number four remember four
words in there he took it all he's a
legend just yeah we got a lot this is
really interesting when I was writing it
out I was like oh I can't wait to get on
Sickler and talk about peace is the
answer and they got to the point where
it was like we either did THC laughs so
how'd you stop the PCP what just same
way it finally was a little okay so you
trance oh you oh so wait you snort a PCP
before you ever did cocaine oh yeah okay
well no man also because you all know a
lot of my radar Aaron was never on my
radar
I'm allergic to pills I throw up I did
not want to do anything that you had to
put in your nose you know the first time
I did that THC crystal for like a week I
felt guilty but I know it's 68 I knew
from the age of six
marijuana was harmless
that people wasting that time with
marijuana I had a godfather that smoked
it he would giggle and I was cold this
is what happens I want to do it I see
all these people arguing all the time
and getting mad and my godfather giggles
of stupid [ __ ] we would sing songs bye
bye miss American Pie I'm the car and
you know it was just the best times
together whenever he got high someone
told me you're gonna yell at me for
telling you I went to the V cafe but I
went to that weed cafe with Josh wolf
but let me tell you something I'll tell
you what I really liked about it no no
people yelling at each other no
arguments no one with their face in
their phone every single person laughing
having a good time actually engaged in
conversation like outside all the
[ __ ] in the novelty and all that
crap it really it was a it was like if
you put a commercial for a weed bar and
an alcohol bar side but it's it's before
and it's night and day it's so different
everyone engaged having a good time not
sloppy you know there's nobody throwing
up over in the [ __ ] corner and you
know the drunk girl tripping over [ __ ]
the guy that's being loud and [ __ ]
all that none of it you don't know
they're smoking don't having a good time
that's waiting and talking and really
engaging and enjoying conversation it
was actually rushing to see food was
good it was pretty good look here's the
thing other people like oh you say it
cuz you're high the truth is it was good
I've been three times and the only
reason I was okay going back because the
food was decent enough it's you could
smoke anywhere out here why am I gonna
go eat at Denny's if just because I can
smoke weed there I don't give a [ __ ]
about weed out front of them gee I had I
tried a bunch of stuff wings Street corn
burger pizza there's a lot I mean their
menus but tacos
everybody got a bunch of different stuff
and we all shared I'm trying to remember
everything but everything was damn good
ribs I think there was like short ribs
not ribs but they were everything was
good I hear you I hear you but also I
don't I'm not a kid I'm not over there
renting [ __ ] you know gravity bombs
and all that
[ __ ] I get my you I think you're allowed
to bring it in I think you are but you
can buy it there and they say you can't
take it home but the whole thing is you
can totally take it home just like give
me a packet at the go or whatever and
I'll bring it to you but you know I just
buy like an individual one I'll tell you
what I did have there that I didn't even
know I liked and I got it by accident
but was just it was a it was a like a it
was almost a cigar wrapped in a cannabis
leaf and you have you had it I think so
yeah
it's fat and that the mouthpiece is a
little glass piece in there
and it's I don't know if Gino has these
big fat ones like that but it was so
good I don't like like I've never been a
blunt fan only because I really liked
the taste of marijuana and I feel like
that cigar wrapper dominates the flavor
I'm tasting that more than I'm tasting
the weed like putting olives on a pizza
I'm tasting the [ __ ] hot I want to
eat the pizza but I really like this
because it wasn't it was marijuana
flavored the the leaf you know and fat
and it was such had a little bit of Keef
sprinkled on it it was [ __ ] amazing
wonderful and you could put it out and
you know pick that one back up and keep
going
that was a good one I just sit there and
smoke and it's this right here at a cafe
eat and there's an outside and inside it
was very well done but also when I was
16 I played soccer for the u.s. on a
under-17 team and I went to Amsterdam at
16 this is 380 389 I'm in Amsterdam and
the Bulldog and every [ __ ] place over
there in the red light district we're
talking 30 years later we're just
getting our first [ __ ] cannabis play
it's it's ridiculous what they've done
Marilyn why weed why you there yep
absolutely walk great and they got the
one dude had a little stance on nickel
and dime bags right at the door if you
just wanted some weed or any of the food
you can get marijuana and you can get it
with or without you know your eggs use
it use it yeah so that was 30 years ago
this was the way don't like it wasn't
Josh knew somebody got us in and then
once I had gone in and they knew I'd
been there they let me in right away and
you can make a reservation
on line two but if you wait on line
you're sitting you know down the
sidewalk and [ __ ] but if you make a
reservation or if you just have a
connection you'll get right in
we waited no more than five minutes to
sit at a table and we got a nice table
serve what you know one person is only
allowed to do food they can't do we'd
one person that's just do weed but I do
think when you when you take that weed
to go to all three times they waited so
long to bring that pack to the table
that I was like I bet you they Bank on
everybody getting high and already
cashing their bill out forgetting that
they ordered that [ __ ] pack it out
they bounced but I waited I don't forget
huh
can I get another one yeah get two I I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't I don't I
don't know
you know man what you guys forget what
everybody forgets is that I'm 57 when I
look 57 one what nothing bothered me
more when I was 22 and old but old guys
who tried after you mm-hmm I don't mind
trying to be young but trying to like
show off like you ever go to a party
there's that old guy with long hair
looking like Jesus made a comeback like
grandpa but you're a lot of places you
walk into I just feel
but if you sat in a bar if you sat in a
bar you wouldn't feel that way you don't
see me in bars but I'm saying you
wouldn't be looked at that way or feel
that way I'll tell you what you're onto
something cuz I always thought I
wouldn't smoke weed with my kids
I thought maybe when they're parents
I'll smoke weed with the kids whatever I
don't want to be the parent and coz I
always in my mind it would been at like
a cookout or some [ __ ] you know what I
mean or a vacation or a wearin Jame
whatever it would have been a special
thing but when I saw Josh brought his
son he was you know Jake it's 22 it's
legal and I never considered in my mind
that there would be the possibility of
smoking weed with my children at a place
where it was legal to sit and everyone's
doing it I never even thought that
thought that crossed my mind you know
and once I saw that I was like oh well
at 21 she'll be able to do it anyway
I would have a drink with
my kid at 21 why wouldn't I smoke with
my kid in this sort of setting so it
changed my mind on it and I hear you
feeling like the old guy trying to be
cool but that of all the places I've
been including any [ __ ] cast I've
seen in Hollywood that preaches
diversity diversity diversity that
restaurant was so [ __ ] diverse in
culture in age and sex and race
everything
it was old white ladies kicking it over
in the corner smoking and laugh and it
was you know young black Asian white
Latino everybody it was a melting pot it
was it was just a nice little thing but
you would have you wouldn't have been
outside no I don't want to go that
that's another thing I wouldn't want it
was history once your [ __ ] lunch you
see your hero doing something yeah I
know because in the environment that I
grew up in you know I don't like that
I'm with you I always felt that way too
you know but you're too when your
daughter's 25 23 you wouldn't have a
glass of wine at Christmas dinner or
some weather you know let's make a mint
I don't see it there's no alcohol in my
house I don't want her to see all right
you know I love when parents are like oh
I've dropped my kid off cuz your kid is
that word over and now it's acceptable
they've seen their heroes doing what
society I'm saying yeah he's all that
it's just a little too creepy from
I like my kids to be a little bit more
cut off with the umbilical cord at that
age
I see too many too many kids young age
connected to them according to their
parents you gotta cut that cord there's
a lot of helicopter parents over yeah
it's I don't know I have weird vibe I
was raised in a house where alcohol was
accepted you raised in a bar
yeah I saw the effects that's why I'm a
cocaine was never I was never gonna do
cocaine because I remember being at the
bar late night and shooting pool by
myself and looking at people what they
had become in the hour that I was
shooting pool
they were snorting coke and now they
were at the bar and they were chatty
they were creepy they would all give me
an extra $10 if I came over and bothered
them but okay you know Welland my mom
did cocaine and I knew when she'd do it
and it's [ __ ] tore me up inside when
she does it special and it's a cleaner
nose yeah so it always bothered me so
for me to [ __ ] ever do coke was never
gonna happen and heroin I got another
horrible story about heroin so that was
never gonna happen but one day I went
downstairs and it was coconut thing and
like I said couple months I was giving
it to a friend of mine to impress him
and then one day I took a little piece
and saved it in my desk I didn't know
why and the night before the kids call
me and they go we're gonna play hooky
and that day we went and we going to
Hudson County Park as we were walking
there up the corner was a beer truck
I'll never forget him that's when we
were robbed beer trucks you rob beer
more than one oh my god you want the
breakfast alright so I would always sign
up for first class first period at 7:30
class that's what time period one is a
lot of my friends were lazy they came in
fourth period
Hallman was 940
the [ __ ] wants to go to school at
minority yeah I want to go to 732 get
over with I would take first period
second period then third pay with study
hall
that means breakfast you know allowed to
leave the building good go to the
Marines [ __ ] on the [ __ ] nice
poppy seed row when they were tight I
solder maybe a bag of wise potato chippy
and Yoho on our Ring Ding and Shan and
strolling and I remember the head
monitors up like you're not allowed to
leave okay
one day suspension good good feel keep
believing that we either went there that
they have no deli that had the best
meatball hero in the country at that
next to it wasn't abandoned go eyes I
was really cold so you could stand there
hey heroine and sparkup okay it was
tremendous why we either went that but
what we talking I break fficer whatever
so we we will walk in the hatchways to
have breakfast and next to Ashley at
that time was a liquor store and that's
when they were one guy it used to be
just one guy and he would get out of his
truck open up the thing with the belt
now is that the old side rolled on yeah
in a garage or if he is he would get the
wheel that dolly dolly the handcart he
would put the five cases on their door
all times he would put 20 cases beats we
time it just perfectly as he turned
around you shot across the street at
that time case and everybody got one we
took three because we're gonna lose what
[Laughter]
we always threw that a truck driver
driver oh yeah hey chase you'll abandon
this truck and then we really robbed the
[ __ ] out of you Oh can't be take the
loss say [ __ ] you there was a safe way
for the Hudson County Park and that
dummy decided to run from the truck one
day and chase the kid that you weren't
gonna catch unless you had a missile he
was like a Puerto Rican his father
agreed he's still second like a mother
second and third and this guy when I'm
embarkment to chase this little Puerto
Rican that was we that's what we like to
bag when they show the television the
order and I of the bar that's what it
was it was like guys picking up a case
because what you wanted to impart you
lost us we want to kind of find this we
could even hide from the cops you can
see the cop flying around with lights
looking for us and we'd be in the
[ __ ] weeds getting [ __ ] what's
that [ __ ] you get from the grass that
you makes you itch II lose my voice in
how I am yeah we would hide and get
poison ivy didn't give a [ __ ] we're a
man Jack oh my baby never killed nobody
Pogo [ __ ] Preparation H on it
preparation I used to get that [ __ ] so
we used to get see bringing up man
poison ivy we have poison oak we had
sumac we had all these things and I
would get it so [ __ ] bad I used to I
got written word from the woods
ringworm how'd you get ringworm from the
wood because he's that because because I
was a dirty [ __ ] kid I was telling my
wife then when I was a five-year-old kid
I stopped wiping my ass right like I
would wipe my ass I would just you would
say [ __ ] put underwear now and go to
school
would say to me Oh what's with these
[ __ ] shitty underwear better feel like
last you listen the next time you give
me a shitty on the way it's open I would
have little kids come over at the house
one day I don't know where that was
plastic like 2 inches in sure my mother
took it and I'm gonna up on the door of
our bedroom when your friends come over
oh my friend come over a year now money
that I wiped my ass I put a hose in my
ass afterward I was a filthy little
[ __ ] spec and I City and I'm like I
was insecure about age I had no friends
yet not like [ __ ] yeah now looking back
and you imagine how bad I stopped as a
little [ __ ] I mean with that's no
wonder I got hit in the head with a
lunch box no wonder those kids attacked
me at [ __ ] Central Park I smell like
[ __ ] as a [ __ ] K but my mom turned
him around and hung him up with my
thumbtacks that she's like until you
learn how to clean your ass your friends
are gonna see you on the rock don't
worry about that cuz my friends ain't
coming over you know I'm good I'm baby
I'm baby white mine everything oh now I
stick my finger up man I got like a
little loofah a loofah loofah not yeah
you play is a home this hold on this is
a homemade thing yeah what you I've had
this loofah for years and whatever gets
warm down AK another piece I wrap around
my the puddles hittin it from the
[ __ ] air well that's flashes well you
get that you rub and you look at the
loofah you get a little what's that
thing that they see Carl masquerade bags
yeah those little hemorrhoids are then
show up and your ass and walks up if you
take a [ __ ] that's dented examine next
time it's dental on the side it's like
when you should have bowled off the gun
has made a certain way so it has things
on it marks sightings or whatever they
call it
you know what gun they came from every
[ __ ] is the same that's why you can
never identify a piece of [ __ ] if you
see a piece of [ __ ] on the street hold
on Oh check that it comes yeah this is
Lisa at SAS go arrest we cyan on the
pretenses because there's no way the
match
I've seen your little talent I might be
able to pick it out which one your shits
we're weird yeah like they're all thin
they're long
oh yeah they're real long especially
after like a 3-day trip buddy what what
we talking about not [ __ ] you were loop
for your egg head loop for my head yeah
you have to at this age you have I
remember when I first I was a girls she
was a girl from Argentina that I dated
to in my 20s and she's like I use baby
wipes take you out just top myself off
here and there or whatever after I go to
the bathroom I use but I was like oh
that's why you always like smell so good
and so nice and then I started using
baby wipes because of her and that's
when I realized oh my ass is definitely
not clean it's not dry toilet paper does
not clean an ass it does not clean and
it isn't amazing I know they have baby
wipes but it's amazing to me that there
hasn't been some sort of wet toilet
paper that's been created yet you know
whenever I go in the public restroom I
go right to the paper towels i wet a
bunch of paper towels and I use wet
paper towels a toilet paper a putting
those public restroom your finger goes
right through that and doing anything
hey I was 21 22 I dated a girl for one
day we broke up I bumped into a month
later and she pulled me aside she goes I
don't mean to hurt your feelings but you
really do have a stinky [ __ ] I can
smell them I suck your dick and that put
me over the top
oh my god was true when you wipe your
ass no service at that time when I took
a [ __ ] I always why wash the toilet
paper I like it in there you know I'll
take an extra two minutes if I'm
traveling the sun's always white [ __ ]
toilet paper if I have to go to a public
bathroom sometimes I'll take toilet
paper wash it and take it into the
private bath yeah I'm that I got baby
wipes in the car I got baby but I always
baby wipe a half inch in for the answer
and take away the mildew in the Malu
and if you bump into somebody they suck
your dick your [ __ ] swells I gotta
clean is theirs and the business yeah
you don't want to [ __ ] stink like
that I had a friend of mine she told me
a story one time about a guy she knew
was friend of hers this made me laugh
sorry it's so [ __ ] up but he went out
one night on a bender got really [ __ ]
up brought this girl back with him she's
equally as [ __ ] up and they have a
one-night stand they pass out he wakes
up in the morning he realizes he is [ __ ]
everywhere all over himself to bed her
but she's still [ __ ] passed out
wasted so he gets up he gets in the
shower real quick here INSAS off he gets
dressed
he leaves his own place but before he
does he leaves a note downstairs it says
you disgusting [ __ ] you did this you
need to get the [ __ ] out of my place
when I get back in a couple hours you
better be gone but he literally took as
she said he packed it on her a little
bit rubbed it on and then made her think
she did it and he got the [ __ ] out of
God that poor girl's probably
traumatized thinks it's probably telling
it's like their worst I think this one
time I went home and I [ __ ] myself all
the guy's house you might even be in
rehab that do [ __ ] blame that [ __ ] on
her because he couldn't got out of there
oh my god that's disgusting that's
disgusting
you got some [ __ ] up friends over
walls and a concert on mushrooms I'm
just right about smoking PCP pregnant
lady yeah you know chillin it's crazy
how if I take off like if I take lead to
a concert
I'll be dead he takes three edibles and
he passes out lean those I'll leave that
the ban passed out while the show we're
gonna get a beer when the show ends I'll
pick him up I'll go leave they pass down
to look at me like I passed out nothing
back come on let's get out of here on
the walk he'll walk out of there people
that's a dude that was passed
that's exactly what I did I wasn't type
of dude you came with me to a shelf and
you passed out of something I left you
right there I didn't know nuts
beeping stepping on you [ __ ] record I'm
not gonna get the member list the band
is doing that best materials over now to
[ __ ] pick you up and let you know it
so you knew the consequences you wait
think I roll a biscuit not be what a
concert has no lights come on I pick you
up I take this the vomit off your shirt
as much as we can and we help you out of
the building how long can I pass on
Farley don't worry about nothing and now
you're walking the feet to New York and
every 20 feet hey that's a guy that was
past that you'll never go to a [ __ ]
concert again and every time I took some
little concert whether they went with me
or friends we don't my hometown went to
so many concerts at the guard that by
the time you get there you're like I
didn't know you were come to sickling
yeah we got tickets four weeks ago are
you see every most of the days that we
have to mail in it mm-hmm oh yeah you
got a mail in a money order and there
was a raffle and then you got chosen so
you get your check back he got four
tickets so you never really knew - a
week before the show good well I mean we
just we slept out on the sidewalk us way
it's it shifted to do you had to be
first in line how crazy remember that
and then Ticketmaster comes along and
you might be first in line going to get
a good scene you're already in the
second section cuz Ticketmaster already
bought up all the [ __ ] probably huh
you see what your ticket Lester came to
business I just want to check we were
just talking about how the [ __ ] it is
amazing how you can't scalp but
Ticketmaster can sell the [ __ ] out of
that [ __ ] called a convenience fee
though we're living in better government
and getting their cut that's all when
you were living them very weird tires 76
huh
76 76 I thought pink floyd-- the wall in
February veiny at that time you would
drive to an office
that was Ticketmaster so pLJ would say
which is the radio station tickets are
going on sale tomorrow 10:00 a.m. with
Pink Floyd you had to go to those
offices there was certainly there was no
gold on it right you had a call
Ticketmaster and see what was the
nearest hub to you that's right we would
there have Macy's they see us rehearsing
wrong yeah but I remember for Pink Floyd
exclusively I remember that we went to
Paramus I think and then we made a
u-turn and went the st. Peter's Prep
there was a Ticketmaster there and that
st. Peter's Prep that nice kids Elvis in
the Pink Floyd we walked in you would
ask Lynn let me get the best tickets you
got right now I'm going to a file you
know and then get like a little ticket
say these are the best I got
and then she'd show you on the map where
you up and tell you you know these are
gonna be you know nothing was I ready to
know 1850 1850
that's very thickly [ __ ] Ozzy 1830
let's do it Ozzy 1850 oh yeah you know
like that was it you know then it I
don't know what Ticketmaster who did
Pearl Jam go to war
take it master yeah take it last now
these actually what the war what they
did you know unless some people really
don't consumer it's very interesting
what's about to happen
two days ago what last week they
announced Netflix and all those
companies pulled out of South by
Southwest oh I didn't know that they
told their employees there weren't a lot
to go just like all these other
companies are going we can't be liable
for you to go to these festivals now
this happened two weeks ago the week of
the 5th of March fifth or agents
grounded
because they can't make a travel on
their own diet but they can't travel on
the company's dime because they could
sue the company because of this
coronavirus yeah you got me thinking I
want to fly to Phoenix with them and
next week no I mean drive drop if you're
ready not a six-hour drive yeah that's
not bad for a little edible with you
giggles Pink Floyd compilation do 90 and
Alison a delicate sound let's stop every
three hours fill up get some to eat and
that's it Monday morning whatever I ran
I don't know it's a one show on Sunday
no show Sunday I'm just Thursday to
Saturday Saturday night after the show
I'll be back 3:00 in the morning yeah
you get back to 3:00 in the morning or
yeah yeah because you don't want to
leave it you want to leave it sadly at
10:00 10:30 right so it's six hours yeah
yeah all right the time I did it I
hooked up with a girl had a Leever in
the hotel rooms and drive and I hit
traffic
I'm thirty minutes away and
bumper-to-bumper traffic oh that's not
that's why I hit you know yeah so if you
get like that Monday morning traffic or
any morning traffic because you got to
go through someone at 15 this at all
connects
Alexia no I mean the 10:00 to 5:00 and
the 101 or all right all right there so
it's kind of its kind of a rough Drive
you know what until we know what's going
on with this coronavirus I mean I'm
pretty much done like I went to the town
he stood two Tuesday's ago and I could
smell it in there
he said that it's it's it's out there I
smelled the last night at a [ __ ]
restaurant my wife went to arrest
the other day she said there was four
[ __ ] tables she was you know how many
times I've gone that and the place is
over back my last night there was only
four tables it people were telling me
that smart and final likes hand
sanitizers gone everything's got gone
and California declared a state of
emergency which New York City will -
well San Francisco did in San Diego did
but la hatton and I'm like if it's in
San Francisco in San Diego it's [ __ ]
here yeah here wow yeah
first case was January 21st Bend and
Seattle Washington I traveled the 25th
and again I saw a higher than normal
amount of Asians traveling it was like a
bomb and throw it off into the country
and they're just getting out and they
just getting out of it I don't blame
them I'm not mad at nobody I'm not
blaming this on me I'm still gonna
believe dr. drew what he says that this
is here if you're older if you have an
immune disorder if you're an infant
obviously you're you could be in trouble
but the flu kills what do you say 80,000
people a year and we don't you know
ain't nobody freaking out about that so
I think we're nothing will be are listen
man it goes back to one thing taking
care of yourself
wash your mother [ __ ] wash your
[ __ ] hands getting your sleep
let me ask you when you they can carry
you so when you meet and greet do you
shake hands I got to start pumping I got
a lot of fists guess what meet and
greets are going away yeah they're gonna
have to I guess you want a fist pump but
I can't take a picture with you I can't
take a picture with you how can we take
pictures now in this climate you want to
take a picture of me after getting on a
plane you gotta be crazy
you come you watch me and you [ __ ]
run out of that and get some real oxygen
you're gonna be very interesting what
the chilling climate might be you know a
lot of Coachella and [ __ ] like that
that's gonna scare our business suffered
yeah you know our business is coming
into the slow season anyway yeah it's
the summer months these what I might say
[ __ ] it why go in there and
we know what the [ __ ] going on with
people I mean listen I went out a couple
of nights ago and people are acting like
there's nothing going on people still
want to give you pumps people still put
not their hands people still want to hug
you I'm at an age where everything I'm
the perfect candidate
don't [ __ ] hug me don't [ __ ]
breathe on me you know I just don't you
know so uh this is part of taking care
of yourself
I've always been washing my hands I
can't believe they let a statistic out
[ __ ] 61% of men don't wash their
hands after they go to the bathroom I
did it I might think I hand shake with a
guy after a comedy show I know I just
touched his hand every man I know masses
ball but yes and I hope they masturbate
with both hands so this writing gig I
just [ __ ] had I would be in there
taking a [ __ ] and these guys would come
in they would [ __ ] they would piss and
they wouldn't wash their hands at all
and I'm like yo what the [ __ ] you don't
[ __ ] and wall back out in there like
that get the [ __ ] out of here
no I'm sick it's pretty it's pretty wild
how people aren't I don't know I'm not a
scientist I'm not a [ __ ] whatever but
I will tell you that am I scared
no it's nothing now Godzilla's running
down Japanese guy running from my life
no but I do have concerns do you see
that other guy had a Ralph's drinking
from the soup I did see that the dude
went into the grocery store the
self-serve soups you know you lift the
lid up the dude took the lato he taste
tested it and then put it [ __ ] back
put it right back in there listen you
need to be all you need to be so take
them out back a tool bag that those days
are over
if you go to a salad place and you take
sound and make your own salad you're
gonna die yeah just assume all that
stuff the breathing or sumn all that
stuff if you go for a supermarket
you're not going to Macy's of gimble and
trying to [ __ ] on milk sugar eggs steak
and get the [ __ ] out you know walk in
the house anymore like oh my god let me
comparison hey what you gotta pay and
get the [ __ ] out of that you don't want
to lurk in that you know which one of
the [ __ ] neighborhoods where people
travel from poor Maz Jobrani a he's
having the hardest time cuz I guess a
lot of Iranians going to his show and
they travel in so he's got to switch it
up or something you know this is just
gonna [ __ ] if you're an intelligent
individual you gotta ask yourself you
know what I don't know you can't believe
people said they came and nobody even
clocked him from money they came in from
Italy and nobody was unknown to me what
about that [ __ ] that that attorney from
New York that went skiing in Italy and
everybody everything's [ __ ] every 18
people have it because they have 18
people how would you feel because you
want to be that special I want to go to
those of the mother [ __ ] this like oh
we're not wearing Jimmy Schubert what
the career yeah he did we Jimmy
Schubert's in Korea shooting a TV show
are you [ __ ] crazy
how long will be in till you talk to
Jimmy yes you gotta go get [ __ ]
decontaminated now I don't what they
tell you good we had a four month I
heard from a trusted friend if the CBC
dropped the ball on this one
they had a four month warning and they
dropped the ball now we're gonna get
Britney ass so I'm not here to instill
danger or harm people
I'm a dick tell you the real reality of
it I don't know much about it so I ain't
gonna [ __ ] with it what was that drug
people were doing years ago and turning
into lizards that was the bath salts a
bad song yeah okay you just thought
three people turn into lizards right why
would you want to do that you want to
give it a try yeah you see what it does
you see what it already does and now you
want to give it a [ __ ] try you want
to give it a spin so that's what pisses
me the [ __ ] off you know what happened
I'm gonna try and do this date but I
have in Nyack I hope it all works out
huh I had eight say I'm worried
are you I mean I am and I'm not you know
what I mean every time I fly I'm always
worried about getting some someone's
[ __ ] [ __ ] in my lungs I feel like
I get sick a lot when I fly especially
during the winter when you're just in a
tube sucking everyone else's [ __ ]
you see these videos putting their feet
up on the [ __ ] [ __ ] they're filthy
they're flopping
that's right they're filthy [ __ ]
animals pigs just assume you know what I
know they tell you you shouldn't assume
it makes em now with me assume you got
old totally we got clean asses the
second day I met Lee I go lead on all
the delivery food no mom why because
your generation believes that [ __ ]
you're too stupid they don't believe
that the delivery people open up come on
he kept doing it he kept doing it what
do we meet ten people I told you what
they did it and then you finally like if
I can't grow up thinking that it's on
the up-and-up guys nothing's on the up
and up that's three sets of hands
touching your [ __ ] food yeah the
[ __ ] guy who cooked the cooked the
packet the person who package is leave
me alone yeah you gotta [ __ ] die and
then at the top of the log some greasy
guy that makes $3 per delivery or
whatever you don't think he opens up
your pizza and takes a piece of little
cheese or pepperoni you're gonna miss it
you're too hungry you're watching the
[ __ ] the the Raider game you know
you're too hungry didn't count the wings
they told you six yeah I'll give you
five and you all know it you know so do
not avoid all that I don't get food to
limit pick it up go pick it up you go to
the green apple you go pick it up
agree that was a good spot that's my
Chinese I know I love these two have
attract me you spot me going over there
doing open mics singing
I'm an Aries and this Chinese breathing
right now they might have brotherly chef
from Rohan not have told this and I beat
the [ __ ] I mean the [ __ ] [ __ ] up
dumpling I'm saying yeah Korona dumpling
yeah Korona dumpling right now you got
I'm not saying to be racist that's not
gonna work but Chinese foods been the
last thing on my mind lately let's just
say you don't say I'm without signing I
could go for some garlic fried rice I
think me [ __ ] pork dumplings a nice
[ __ ] French style philemon yeah it's
[ __ ] whatever it's went so I'm right
on the meat there was went to
understanding well I love other people
give it up you just go light on it you
still you stick with that yeah that's
you huh see that was always pizza for us
on Friday you know what I mean roll it
up again my Friday yeah peas and a
shrimp or crab nice muffin red myself
with that red floor and you eat that
muscle then you take a slice of pizza oh
my god yeah I got high a couple times
this weekend destroyed yeah and then I
[ __ ] went to Joe's I bumped into Gino
from speed we in by the way is
sponsoring the 4/20 uncle Joey's 4/20
show eight o'clock Tommy still are you
got the Netflix festival you have to
Montreal Comedy Festival and you got the
Joey Diaz [ __ ] fest
for 20th the [ __ ] Comedy Store bring
edibles cuz we're going deep into the
murky waters boat was they saying he saw
Gino at Joe's Latino it I saw Gino and
he gave me one of those joints and I
smoked it by the commies talked about
myself 18 points left eyed points left
for that box that day so I was a no
camper like 16 I brought like 30 minutes
of boxing I don't put the whole hour
I put 30 minutes there she how much do
you really moving so I had points to
burn and I wanted to [ __ ]
Joe's pizza the other night storm to the
hills 11:15 I double parked my car put
my hands inside I walk right in there
they don't let me get to Grandma's
pizzas the ones with the mozzarella on
the end and it's loose oh my god I ate
two of them and I got in the car I want
a diet Snapple and as I was gonna make
the left turn oh let me take two more
just for the leak as I hit the 100 [ __ ]
we [ __ ] pizza uh that's the spot man
what's going on with your podcast
brother
all good things right now you got an
episode coming out the honey-do podcast
you can follow it on social media
honey do podcast calm I got some dates
gonna tell my date what's your next for
stand up I'm gonna do a special for but
I also love to produce I like you know
I've had I've been able to work on some
shows that help sell and got some shows
coming up that I really want to work on
Josh wolf and I are starting a new one
coming up here I'm starting one with
Simone - and thank you that whatever you
just did brought it back brother I don't
know I want to stay in the digital space
TV's dying it's dead these people are
these people are either getting fired
laid off let go or they're getting
promoted new people don't want there's
so many things that that that could
happen to derail anything outside of you
having talent or a great idea or
anything and if you just put it all on
digital it lives there and the people
can go there and watch it there's nobody
it's killing your you know digital
channel unless you doing some crazy
crazy [ __ ] but I don't do that so yeah I
want to create more content some digital
shows it'll be really exciting and stuff
coming up I can't really talk about yet
but you'll be you'll be a part of it
you'll be seeing it all look so yeah
that's that energy I be right there
look at me I'm so excited and I'm doing
the road I'm doing I got some some some
dates around the country this year that
I'm excited to go where's your website
at it's Ryan Sickler calm go there go
subscribe to my youtube that's where I'm
gonna start putting a lot more stand up
I'm gonna start putting some more
exclusive content there and really build
that channel up I'm out in Phoenix in a
you know tell you watch 21st of March 20
is you know my dates better than me
I gotta let's see here
March 19 I think I'm the are you yeah
when you go you fly out when I fly out
yeah March 19th to the 21st I'm in
Phoenix I'm at the La Jolla Comedy Store
March 26th I'm at the rec room and
Huntington Beach you ever done that yes
dude I love that spot I love it and then
I'm up in Vancouver
April 23rd through the 25th no date
today Oh April with August and no no no
people like told by eight the other girl
I remember and then I don't baby enjoys
they're gonna feed up that's all they
need to do right now Vancouver Phoenix
La Jolla Huntington Beach Simone and
I'll be doing another monthly at the
store in April if you'd like to come on
you're always welcome good for you you
put it together
I'm keeping it going and all of this is
just staying busy that's all it is
until the next fastball comes down the
fire that's it that's all it really is
you got to stay anyway just can't
understand that it's just listen it's
eight spots a week you gotta do this you
gotta do your two podcasts and sometimes
it seems boring get ready
it gets even worse but if you put in
this work eventually a fastball comes
down the pipe somebody sees you miss
things they want to use you for this
thank you for this you know good ideas
you gotta pay people a little money you
gotta get involved you know go get
finite and do something call some
Chinese people telling them making
videos I'm saying send me five thousand
you're in the Union corporation sponsors
Lisa I had dancing with a ball of his
head don't matter
as long as they're paying the freight
and you're at home shooting it videos
that's what you know who knows where
we're gonna go with this disease and
these trains times me I hope this thing
just dies and we move on yeah well
American yeah that's it but uh it's what
you surround it with it that's it
me I'm gonna keep taking showers lifting
my little weight drinking my tart cherry
juice - well it's is it loofah in your
[ __ ] move from my [ __ ] sleep in my
8:00 you know I take care of my stats a
big but that's the other thing right
there that's especially me we don't have
no idea that that's the master one
that's sleep is the one going eventually
I do sit they say you can never catch up
on it you know what I mean like once
you've missed it it's not like I'll
sleep ten tomorrow now it's you've
already done the damage once your body
misses it you catch up and you sleep
deep
I don't even wake up in the middle of
like to pee no more I got this new THC
drink bite can calm oh that's what that
called yeah Elmo teas it's called sleep
it does what it says oh it's only three
milligrams of THC the rest to CBN mean I
don't even wake up and I got the tablets
for the road Oh sleep right through that
Corrado
I hate him in Vegas I experiment that
with them in Vegas when I woke up I
couldn't even [ __ ] set the coffee
machine for real I had a call room
service I was still [ __ ] up next this
cropped machine just ate four cups and a
lot of sweet um the blue package is
always a pleasure thank you Ron excuse
me for that thank you for always Adam
that's a book that suppose like a
vitamin that's all I've had today
there's a protein shake
can you believe that no me being a fat
[ __ ] that's okay shaking an apple what
the [ __ ] lives off that but I'm the gall
to blast it with protein just jumping up
and down that's it always a pleasure how
language that real
all I got going on is March 27th and
Santa Barbara at their Arlington theater
tickets are still available and 420 at
the [ __ ] Comedy Store 417 and
at the Reno and 4:18 in Portland
somewhere I don't know I'll let you know
next week and now for a word from our
sponsors the church is brought to you by
stamps.com listen all you need is a
computer to print postage 24/7 any
letter or any size package going
anywhere in the world you could do it
right from your couch like how Joey
stamps calm it's time is money baby
stop wasting time going to the post
office when you could use stamps calm no
more waiting in line at the post office
you're the post office now jack and the
best part is the mailman will come and
pick it up from you no more lugging
boxes to your [ __ ] car you got to go
there you got to make it on five o'clock
you got to get online you don't have no
more excuses time is the only thing you
say you'll be saving with stamps calm
get five cents off every first class
stamp up to 40% off shipping never pay
full price again how many more times do
I got to do you got expect to the
post-office in your [ __ ] life
how many more and I give a [ __ ] some
humbly potatoes were like [ __ ] eat
it's the same thing how many times will
I go to the [ __ ] post office
stop going down there you stamps calm
and right now they got a special offer
for the church family you're ready for
this one a four-week trial plus postage
and a digital scale no long term
commitments or contracts it's easy you
go to stamps calm click the microphone
at the top of the homepage and then
press in church that's it that stance
calm press in church and never go to the
post office or getting a coffin I want
to thank my man Ryan Sickler I want
anything [ __ ] but most
important I wanna thank you for
listening for supporting us and always
having our back we got some weird
conversations here gives a [ __ ] we can
hear this type of [ __ ] nowhere anyway I
love you [ __ ] have a great
weekend
stay safe don't let people breathe on
you don't go somewhere with a bat milk
or whatever the [ __ ] I don't give a well
the restaurant is so great it's a fusion
I listen mind your business
all those fusion places or creepy people
they like to travel it wouldn't when
they were in Singapore this year and
they brought it back with the met [ __ ]
Kerry's why take the chance in this case
you're not Columbus mind your business
stay at home jerk-off you don't know
nothin listen to podcast
have a great week a great weekend and
we'll come back next week and have a
good time all over again I love you
[ __ ] that ghetto kick this
[ __ ] melee